Hello everybody, good morning everyone.
I am so tired.
It's so early for me.
Oh, the things I do for deaf.
But don't worry.
I brought my dog to the rave.
Once, once, once, once, and one more time, but...
I brought Dad to the ring.
Let's go.
One more time.
We got a live 2025 in Fortnite.
Okay.
I hope my sound guy is alive.
this is the this is i forgot to tell my sound audio team to like get ready for the audio balancing
okay because i'm bringing dad to the rave give me a sec we gotta move up a little bit so dad can fit in fit in all right we'll do it here and then Whoa.
This is important.
He has to be here.
Fiction.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Harder, better, faster, stronger.
My first ever sound of sound and catching me.
But I can't remember it was deaf.
Thank you for the super chat.
Fiction.
Thank you.
All right.
We'll bring it a dog to it.
What's this?
What's the dog doing?
He's coming with me to the rave.
That's what he's doing.
Oh, shit.
The Megazoid pack.
I didn't even know.
All right.
So for those who don't know, after 18 years, Daft Punk is finally going to do a live 2025.
But it's on Fortnite.
And we're here for the death fuck experience.
I don't care that it's in Fortnite.
I waited 18 plus years.
Oh my god.
It's here.
It's finally.
Who the fuck is Mr. Savage?
The first thing I should see is death fuck.
get out of here get your ass oh my gosh look at that there's kicks oh my god there's new shoes oh anyway daft punk time oh my god look at them they're so french there it is don't keep i hated the So long.
The disrespect.
The disrespect on Daft Punk.
It's Daft Punk Day.
Why the fuck is Mr. Savage on the front page?
How dare you disrespect Daft Punk?
Oh my.
All right.
It's time.
All right, guys.
Oh, I'm ready.
To use my creator code.
Jokey Bird.
If you are buying Daft Punk cosmetics right now.
now oh my god it comes with their double guitar oh and the silver battery bag oh my god this is from this is from their um during their what was it the 90s slash 80s this was their costume in the 90s slash 8 okay we gotta i wish i wish they had their classic outfit like the the og because like okay it sucks okay this is some daft punk look this is how invested i was in daft i love daft punk so much i always been oh my god i should have tweeted i oh my god i forgot to take a picture of the helmet that i have it's actually here with it's actually okay so these was like in the um 90s 80s their outfit during that time but they don't have it for they don't have the og outfit skins which sucks because like the helmet i i i like their helmet for this uh for for this version this is like their their very first their very first outfit but they don't have it this is like the i mean the the black leather jacket is a classic too but like the led i think like the discovery for their discovery era
helmets or the their best helmets in my opinion because of the LEDs yeah so now now they don't have the LEDs anymore but um um it's just like you know it's just pitch black but I think the LEDs were my favorite all right let's buy let's buy G Manuel and Tomah all right where is it view offer do I have all right we don't have enough vbooks give me a sec all right we're gonna use my creator oh my god there's Lego versions of them I didn't even notice Oh my god,
look at how tiny you are.
Oh, you guys can't see.
Okay, give me a sec.
Look how tiny he is.
Look at it.
How tiny.
Oh my goodness.
Look at it.
I saw this.
Get a bonnet to get lucky.
Oh, does it auto?
Oh, that is.
Oh, yeah.
There you go.
The xenomorph.
Look, the xenomorphs need it to get lucky.
um no no i'm the alien band the power knight to some she's on power knight to get some power knight to get some my power knight to get lucky she's on power knight to get some the power knight to get some my power knight to get some my power knight to get lucky i up the volume a little bit there This is a post-cray scene on aliens.
Around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world,
around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world.
is this
it's crazy oh my god it's the whole i can't believe it it's the whole song in the fortnite evo Okay, I got two zoning, it's around the world.
You know when around the world plays and you're just like, Around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world.
Okay, let me up it.
Okay.
I can't help it when it's...
When that song plays, you just want to go...
Around, around, around, around.
Around.
You can't help it.
It's just...
It's there, and I want to go around.
Someone did...
Someone did a challenge.
Not challenge, but they, they went around the map with that emote.
And they were like, it took me...
They were saying how it took them, like...
four hours to go around the map with um with the around the world emote
what's my favorite album that's i i think it's like i won't say album it's more like what's my favorite song um i think my oh my gosh it's so hard because they're all so good i don't think i have a favorite i think i just loved about it i just love all their songs like even the oh wait technologic you only know what okay i think i okay i i don't remember if i told you guys oh we gotta buy that okay we have to sorry we have to we gotta get in we gotta get okay where i got it okay um did i buy it that okay so technologic is my favorite song because it was actually the very first song i've ever listened to from Daft Punk and the only the reason how oh I should I sorry let's buy this first um let's buy this first and queue up before I tell you the origin of my Daft Punk love alright claim all it's time to be King Manuel he's actually really short in real life that's why like this is like crazy because this guy is like here because I like just how how invested I am and I know their heights
um I know the height difference he is Gimuel is a short king he's he's actually here and Toma is like here he's he has to be honest so there's no way he is he is at the same height they are not the same height he's like he has to wear heels to match his height like he's like here i even know their heights that's how how hardcore of a deaf punk fan i am all right all right let's let's swap it's okay uh i'm keeping the kicks on i'm keeping it on i know like okay i i'm wait edit styles was this reactivity okay we got reactivity on i don't know what it does um but we have to i'm gonna keep keep the classic the the retro version um and then uh backpack where's my daft bump backpack where is it okay we'll put his normal backpack on and then his guitar
oh my god i forgot i think i think he had the double guitar oh my god i'm trying to remember
lose your i think he was the one with the double guitar it's fine i want him with a double guitar anyway it's the classic it's a classic anyway oh my okay he's gonna be on chen ron he's in fake magic but okay the guitar i don't remember the guitar okay i think it was i think he had i think i'm pretty sure he had the double guitar i had to like double check okay all right he i'm gonna have him wear oh my god i want him to wear converse actually I feel like it fits more.
I mean, I don't know if I want it with Air Jordans or Converse.
I think I'll give him Converse.
He'll have Converse.
All right, it's time.
Queuing up the Death Punk.
Okay, so I don't remember if I told you guys the story, the origin of my Death Punk love.
But the reason why, like, how I got it, like the lore of how I got into Death Punk is because, I downloaded the app Tap Tap Revenge on the iPhone and one of the free songs you get was Technologic.
So I was playing Tap Tap.
And I kept playing Technologic over and over again.
And I was like, man, this song is so good.
I was like, whoa.
I was like, who sang this song?
This song is so fucking good and it was it was technologic it was technologic and that's how i got introduced to daft punk yeah i was a i was just i just love that song so much it was it was life-changing um oh my god hello my fellow daft punkers oh my god he's like oh by the way i own that necklace you see the I actually,
I own that necklace.
I have that one in real life as well.
Hello, my fellow Daft Punkers.
Yeah, I do.
I actually do.
I own one of these.
The necklace is there.
This one specifically.
I was just, I was a Gimmon Well fan.
I'm sorry, Tomah, but I just, I don't know.
There's just something about him that, I don't know.
I think he was my favorite member in Daft Punk.
I don't email it again.
Oh my god, around the world.
Around the real world with Miku Hatsune.
Don't worry.
We'll go around the world together.
Oh, we can't, we...
Around the world, around the world, around the world, around the world.
I love how this guy is just like, I'm ready.
He's just looking at...
I think he's looking at the timer.
Yeah, he's like...
He's locked in.
He's like, I waited 18 years for this.
No one is stopping me from experiencing Daft Punk.
No.
My whole life.
I'm ready.
Don't just don't interrupt me I am ready Here for the vibe Oh yeah you're right I should Let me adjust all the settings for this
That's right it's all epic I am so ready That's fucking right It's all on epic Oh, this should be high.
Alright, 90.
It's Daft Punk.
It should be the 90.
Alright.
I'm like, I waited so long.
I'm like, this is it.
We've been waiting for this forever.
We're up all night.
You want a louder game?
Okay.
Yeah, I don't think my sound guys are alive today.
All right, any of my mods, you are now temporary promoted to sound team.
Oh my god, they even have to get lucky, son!
It's right there!
Okay, how do I emote?
Okay.
I'm so ready.
He is...
Wait, what happened to the other Daff Puck member?
Wait, there was...
It was like, oh my god, even the power rangers are here.
One more time.
I brought my dog to the rave, too.
You think the...
Oh my god, the music stopped.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, it's new music.
I was like, what happens to the music?
five minutes guys five minutes we're all so oh my god we're all so ready oh my god is that a fucking Zoid right there what the fuck is up wait who's over there I think that's where all the other Daft Punk member went Jakarta thank you for the super chat thank you thank you wait you're not Daft Punk What the fuck?
Is someone up over there?
Who's up over there?
Who the fuck is up on that mountain?
Oh, Tomah!
Tomah!
Hello, Tomah!
There you go.
Hello.
Oh my god, we're synced up.
Oh my god, it's perfect.
We're meant to be.
They're aura- Oh my god, yesterday I was watching There's also What the fuck?
Okay, yesterday Um Also why I would Um, I sort of slept late Was because I was watching Lovewick was hosting the The speedrun event On his channel And I was watching the vibe of some of the speedruns Cause it was very interesting Cause like one of the speedruns Okay,
I got the rabbit hole was the clip of uh a clip of uh the peak speed run was out and i was like wait you can speed run click a peak i was so confused i was like what the how do you speed run peak and let's create this guy solo solo climb the entire mountain in 20 minutes and like i was watching like i was watching him do the
um the lava land and it was so it was so stressful yeah it actually go crazy and like the thing is it's the items are rng but they had used they use like set mountains so like you know it's not like they're going through the mountain blind so they have a path for it but the item spawning in is like all rng the items and like the the suitcases and everything yeah so i was just like Yeah,
so it was like glitchless run and I was just watching them like fucking zoom like they never got hungry And it was so fast that like the the hunger bar never like went down That's that's crazy I thought and then he got the guy got top 20 on the speedrun stream Yeah I it was fucking crazy to watch because he was just like
It's just, it was like, I'm like, Jesus Christ, he doesn't even have a hunger bar.
Oh, the slab.
Oh, my God, it's pulsating.
Oh, my God.
I'm sorry, I gotta leave.
I gotta go to the focus cell, locked in.
Holy shit.
It's pulsating.
I just
get the timer.
He's counting down the return, the slab, the slab, I feel like the monkey discovering the slab right now and then learning how to talk after I touch it.
Don't distract him, he's so real for this, he's just aura farming right now, he waited his entire, entire life for this moment.
Return to the Slab.
The mysterious monolith.
Papa Smare, thank you for the Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
See my Oshi, geek at her Oshi's peak.
I wait, I woke up at 10 a.m.
for you, Daft Punk.
Oh my god, I'm so excited.
Ah!
I read a little bit of spoilers, like the leaks and stuff, of like what to expect in the Daft Punk experience.
But apparently, like, because it's several rooms that you get to visit.
And the first room is, like, a, the recreation of Alive 2007.
So I'm so fucking excited.
I'm so jealous of everyone, of anyone that got to experience Alive 2007.
Because I remember seeing, like, videos of it and the stage design.
It looked so cool.
Like, it had to be, like, a life-changing experience.
And I'm getting this in Fortnite.
Fortnite.
Fortnite shall change the trajectory of my life.
Oh my god.
25 seconds.
Turn up the music.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Uh.
There we go.
It's a hundred.
Oh.
Five.
Four.
three two one people need me
my people need me now
enter this lab oh oh my god my helmet reflects too that's so cool hey bob i'm looking at what uh it's definitely not a particle that's nearby it is a bright object and it's obviously rotating so beautiful the world
so beautiful
woman the crescent does don't worry it's here oh
my god holy
Fuck.
Oh my, that was crazy.
Oh my god.
Where I go?
No, we can't explode.
We can't explode.
No, we just got here.
No!
Not the trauma!
Why would you give me PTSD?
No!
No, I didn't kill!
Oh my god, it's the LEDs!
We're going in.
Oh my god, it's the robot!
It's the robot!
Oh my god!
We're here!
It's a robot!
Oh my god.
I don't want to go to the next room.
Okay, we're lagging a little bit, which is a little fortunate.
Oh my god.
I wish I wasn't lagging a little.
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
It's fine.
Yeah, babe.
Bring it, bring it, bring it.
Let's be mad.
Touch it for it, babe.
Oh my god.
Turn it into a cinematic.
Touch it, bring it, babe.
Alexa, bring it to me, bring it, camp però mad at you, get搞, go, shake, bring it, let's just bring it, let's do this, drop from at it, I just ring it, be, touch it, return it, bring it, set, drop it, bring it, drop it, drop it, use it, drink it, oh my god,
ah, ah!
All
right, I'm not here, playing, just bring your, cloac sound to the ground the ground, the ground, song, papa down here, stick you're in it, Watch it, watch it, watch it, watch it Watch it, watch it Watch it, watch it Watch it, watch it, watch it Watch it,
watch it, watch it, watch it, watch it Watch it, watch it, watch it Watch it, watch it Watch it, watch it, watch it, watch it Watch it, watch it, watch it, watch it, watch it Watch it, watch it, watch it, watch it, watch it, watch it,
I'm at it.
Not yet.
Woo!
Yeah, yeah.
There's a ball of music.
I'll just play it.
You're attracted!
Ah!
Terrorism nation.
Around No.
Television, through the nation,
television, through the nation around the world around.
I'm ready.
Through the nation, the world,
Through the nation.
Around the world.
The world.
Oh my god.
We're going around the world.
The world.
This is why I brought my dog to the rave.
I hope it's not too loud, but they deserve it!
Bye!
Dad's first rave.
I brought him to the first EDM concert.
Through the nation!
Oh, it wasn't just the settings, but...
Through the nation.
A vision.
I want my brain to rattle
Oh Oh Oh
God wait Oh my god wait Oh
my god wait Don't worry I want to join you guys
Boom, boom.
Television.
Through the nation.
Oh.
Oh, when you're here.
Oh, my God.
They synced it up.
These guys are hard.
They're hardcore.
They have to be duels.
They're like actual syncing it up and everything.
Oh my god, there they are!
My Oshis!
I don't care if I'm lagging.
This is beautiful.
Oh.
I'll go to the next room after this guys I have to see you to the last
I can't do it us oh
hi there hi there that's you younger
oh my god around the world around the world around the world Hey, that's it stronger.
This is my gym Right here Around the world around the world
We're so high up
We're around the world around the world around the world Around the world, around the world, around the world
I love the guy that's on the fucking globe
You're right, we're here's my Do it, that's your strength is stronger And then it's over Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh
I'm tripping
I'm multi-tripping
It's the other way I don't know how to Faster, faster, faster, faster Work it, work it, work it, work it Harder, harder Work it, work it, work it Faster, faster, faster Work it, work it, work it Harder, harder, harder, harder Work it, work it, work it Faster,
faster, faster I can't fight in our hood all right, I'm sorry!
Oh my god, we're bugged
We're bugged!
Oh It's fine.
It's fine.
I Can still experience it.
Oh
No You serious I'm I can't I fucked up My
time my window you can't stop me.
All right.
I'll do dancing One more time All right, oh yeah, and there's dances.
Oh my God, they missed it.
One time we're gonna celebrate.
Oh yeah, all right, I'm trying to dance it.
One more time, we're gonna celebrate.
Oh yeah, all right.
Oh my God, they got the whole crescent pose over here.
We're on our own fun.
Oh my God, we, our floor.
I think everybody dc'd on on one more time because so many people loaded into the lobby at that time the floor is lava
Not ever but a lot of people.
We loaded it in one more time.
Oh my God, the segues are so good.
Oh my God.
They're so good.
I love them so much.
Yeah!
She clapped.
It's just us.
Why would you ever watch this close?
I feel like you get better experience from up here.
Oh!
Oh my god, was that everything?
my god oh they're so good oh my god that's it oh my god we did it oh my god this
is my square what do you want from a stepbook we're all here
oh my god
you can sit down here he's just enjoying the concert whoa
Oh my god, the fact that the stage also jams through the music.
Oh my
god, wait, they're all driving down here, wait, I got around the world with them.
Guys, let me in, let me in, let me in, I want to around the world too.
I want to around the world with you guys.
Nice.
Oh, wait, there's no more.
No, I missed out.
Oh, I missed out around the world with them.
Oh,
the way he looks like he met well, you know, his friends forever.
The way he looks at him.
roommates.
They're just French.
Are they gay or European?
Yes!
Let's all do the walk!
Oh, the crowd's back!
Oh, in the air!
Whrrr!
Oh my god!
Look at her!
Up in the air.
Up in
the air.
Up in the air.
in the air up in the air up no I'm stuck no they can't do this to me no don't kick me out no no up in the air up in the air up in the air up in the air no no up in the air up in the air oh oh I can still watch this up in the air up in the air up
Oh my god!
Oh my god it's lagged this concert!
There's the black, there's the digital black hole!
Oh The pirates made their faces Yeah Oh Oh Oh Oh Yeah
I should have been an E-Rog!
Oh!
Oh
my god, Encore!
Is it restarting?
Or is it an Encore?
But...
No!
This is... Okay, restarting!
I missed out the Robot Rock.
I'm watching Robot Rock because I missed it.
Robot Rock.
Why did he cover?
Oh,
yeah, but we never got to watch Robara!
Oh, yeah.
My name is Robara.
VALYONOME VALYON
VALAYA Robot Rock
Robot Mario Robot Rock
Banana Banana
Banana Banana Banana
Banana What?
Robot Rock Rock, rock, rock Rock, rock, rock
Oh my god Alright, it's time for Maddie Watch it, bring it, brave, watch it, turn it, leave it, stop for maddock, touch it, bring it, babe, watch it, turn it, leave it, stop for maddock, just turn it, leave it, stop, for maddock, turn it, leave it, stop,
or maddock, touch it, okay, now we're looping back, ah, it's so good, though, turn it, bring it, stop, or maddock, touch it, turn I'm stuck oh no You're not leaving No, no, no
Ah, it's okay, it's okay It loops It loops, it's okay It's fine Oh, it's fine, it loops We're okay, it loops Anyway, we can actually go back to We can go and experience the other rooms Party's over now get out.
You've watched it.
You stayed too long.
I'm sorry.
I just wouldn't experience a life twice.
And Kate really was like, next room, please.
Please, Dokia.
You, you've been squatting for too long.
It's next room.
I'm sorry.
It's just, I'm sorry!
It's like I stayed for the next showing at the movie theater.
I just, one more time, you know?
One more time!
Alright, someone said to turn this off.
Newman.
Okay, would I stop lagging here?
To the next room we go.
one more time but I know dream make your own mixes whoa wait
what would it look like if I there's more there's a several rooms the first room is the most important room really and see what it looks like the first room is the most important in one how do we remix what
oh oh that is so cool that is so cool okay wait i'm gonna close this oh oh it's like a soundproof dome
okay technologic Oh my god they have their entire They have their entire album
Okay we gotta Turn it down just a little bit
How do I mix it up Pick on the other side
Oh I do Wait what
Oh I can't even change the tempo
Wait oh my god there's something about us oh
i'm jamming i'm dj toky
Never Hour after hour Work is never over Work it on the Make it better Do it faster Make sense stronger All that Never Hour after hour Work is never over Work it on the Make it better Do it faster Make sense stronger Only never Work it Make it better DJ Duke is cooking Work it on the Make it better Do it faster Make sense stronger Work it ever Hour after Oh
My god, just speed it up
Get out leave This is my leave Sweet Look what leave my jam house This was my jam!
Okay.
Wait, doing it right?
I'm doing it right?
Okay.
Lose yourself to dance, maybe?
This is my creation.
I made this.
DJ shows you.
The secret third member of Daft Punk.
The D in Daft Stads for Doki.
There's so many that you can do.
It's crazy.
Oh my god, this even works.
Wait, leave!
Leave, leave!
Leave, this is...
Leave!
This is my jam!
I'm jamming!
That's right, that's right, you know, you know my, it's already perfect.
You already know, you already know this song is already perfect, Gail!
They have invaded the jam sphere.
They didn't touch anything, they knew already, it was perfect.
Nothing needs work here.
The only person I'll collab with is the other two members of Dapple.
You can't stop me.
We're gonna celebrate.
You do not mess with Pete.
One more time.
We're gonna celebrate.
Oh yeah, all round.
I'm gonna dance in.
One more time.
I'm gonna celebrate it.
Oh yeah.
One more time.
I'm gonna celebrate it.
Oh yeah.
All of us got to dance in.
One more time.
I'm gonna celebrate it.
Oh yeah.
One more time.
The macarito It works!
Yes, we don't stop.
It's so good.
Oh my, I went to check the other rooms, though.
We leave the jam sphere.
We have to leave.
I feel like I could be there for hours.
Just jamming it up.
Oh, my God.
I honestly feel like I could be there for a while.
Wait, this guy's jamming, too.
Or is he being picked?
Instant crush get lucky in our room.
the world good choice good choice okay
this guy's a good jam too I'm letting him cook he's cooking right now
he left the jam spear I was jamming how could you leave the jam sphere while I'm jamming that's up bro that's fucked up no I was jamming in the jam sphere oh shit oh shit okay I thought I was gonna die in the jam sphere but how do I go to the next room you was cooking that's messed up where's the next Which is the next room?
Because that goes back to the concert.
Doesn't that go back to the concert?
Oh, we have to enter back here.
TP.
No, we're...
Alright.
Oh!
Wait, how many rooms are there?
We go to the red room.
Oh my god, Daff Club.
five rooms okay what's this room the deaf club
oh my god they're just out there watching us dance i that's yes dance my little humans dance for our entertainment.
Oh my god, we're at a disco.
Don't worry, I'll dance for you.
I'll dance to my robot overlords.
We like so much.
She's a fun night to get some.
I'm a fun night to get some.
She's a fun night to get one.
I'm a fun night to get lucky.
I'm up all night to get sun, I'm up all night to get sun, I'm up all night to get sun, I'm up all night to get sun, I'm up all night to get lucky, we're up all night to get lucky, we're up all night to get lucky, we're up all night to get sun, we're up all night to get sun,
we're up all night to get sun, we're up all night to get sun, we're up all night to get sun, we're up all night to get sun, we're up all night to get sun, we're up all night to get sun, we're up all night to get sun, we're up all night to get sun, we're up all night to get sun,
we're up all night to get sun, we're up all night to get sun, we're up all night to get sun, we're up all night to get sun, we're up all night to get sun, we're up all night to get sun, we're up all night to get I'm a fun night to get lucky, I grew harder!
I love this seed from Tron.
Are you pleased, Master?
Does this bring you joy?
Oh, I got dance to the camera pads around you?
Oh,
I got dance in a pad.
Oh!
Oh, we already saw it one more time.
We already saw it.
But the crescent does.
We watched the entire concert.
This in VR would be insane though.
The concert, if Fortnite re-uploaded the whole event and if
they re-uploaded all of it into VR it would be such a cool experience.
We're up all night to get lucky We're up all night to get lucky We're up all night to get lucky We're up all night to get lucky We're up all night to get lucky We're up all night to get lucky We're up all night to get lucky We're up all night to get lucky It's just sitting there We're up all night to get lucky I like how Kamal is just sitting there He's like hey
Hello, Tama.
Dance with me.
Oh my god.
Wait, where did all these people come from?
I turned around for one.
I looped one second.
And like, where did this Tama came from?
Oh my god, where did he come from?
To Tama?
That's how it starts.
What's this one?
They're here, they're getting lucky.
Will he disappear if I turn around?
No, he's still here.
We're just entertaining our robot overlords.
Oh my god, he's gone now.
Squirt, squirt, squirt, lose yourself to dance.
Lose yourself to dance.
oh my god i can be here forever but i have to go explore the other rooms i'm sorry i'm sorry i hope i entertain you my oh she's i'll be back i was losing myself through the dance
wait are these the tron suits wait no they're the led suits never mind they're the the og led suits all right which one have i that's the concert okay three wait one two three that means i'm missing one more room
is this one of the rooms robot last robot to the beat how long can you survive yes
all right It's blaster time.
Oh, wait, I want to...
What if I play your mode?
What if I join him?
It's not working right now?
No!
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Evil Goku.
Gorillas.
What am I?
Oh, my God.
Wait, this is sick.
Do I have to shoot my teammates?
Oh, here it is.
What's this?
Oh
It's like a way it's um it's waves
Oh my gosh do music with the power of music oh my god I'm actually making tracks while I kill them I'm making beats
music hiator this is my beat track
33 oh my god there's so he's I oh I didn't see him oh my god now I was like this is easy now there's a little too many people
Don't worry, I'll save you!
My fellow chat bunker!
Oh!
I'm sorry.
I work is never over.
The way I got you.
Oh, no.
I'll stay.
Oh, they're dead.
It's just me.
I'll never know.
Wait, I like this one.
I'm going to use the blue.
I'm remixing right.
right now.
I don't care if this doesn't work.
That's on him.
He died.
Literally remixing with my shooting.
Oh god, there's so many.
Are you not entertained, my robo overlords?
Oh my god, it's way five.
I've been a few.
Oh.
Yeah, why would I ever swap from the blue?
Other than the fact that it kills the reds a little faster.
The blue is just a better option!
Oh my wait.
stuff here oh my god my my overlords don't want me to have this understandable you're right
oh my god I just want to hear the robot I don't care about that fucking beat holy shit they're lining up wait where did these guys come from.
Oh, they're stuck here forever.
Wait, they're still alive.
They're just crawling in.
They're crawling listening to my jab.
He can't leave.
They're forced to listen to my jab.
I care about this jab.
Oh my god.
Why is there not more blues?
I'm...
Look at my ribs!
I can't help them!
I'm just surprised they're still alive!
I thought they were dead!
I thought they were... I thought they left!
Why are they still here?
They're stuck here forever listening to me jamming.
I'm just trying to give them a good experience.
Oh, it's not my fault.
The rest takes like 20 years.
Is that him?
Don't worry!
I got you!
Who are...
I'm sorry, it's too late.
It's too late for you, but I can still live on.
You gotta keep crawling.
It's too late for you.
I live in your memory.
I can't believe he's still here.
Does he know how to leave?
The other guy even know how to leave?
Is he still here?
Let's check.
He's gone.
He finally left.
I think.
Unless he's like crawling somewhere else.
Oh my god.
I feel like.
Alright.
The moat.
Did it repeat?
I don't remember.
Oh my god.
I'm just a one man crew right now.
Hot rod.
Oh my god.
The combo.
There's a group.
John.
Green yellow high.
A green heart green yellow.
Got it
We are solo player shit
My team died so fast.
I don't even know how they died.
I'm only I just I feel like I could get to the next wave So easily if I had an actual team The song repeats.
That's it.
Kill me.
I'm over this.
It loops.
I'm done.
It's 20 waves.
We're not getting to the 20 wave.
I survived eight waves by myself.
I'm like, I'm done.
When it started looping I was like it's over how many we're missing two more rooms right or is it just one room left purple
basement it's below the stairs like how they're just like sitting there oh are these NPCs oh yeah I was like I was sitting here and it's just an NPC.
Oh, here you go.
Select this, okay.
Hello.
It's so tiny.
This.
Hello.
Alright, go around, no around.
Own Lego version of the iconic music video.
Wait.
Do all these dances?
Oh my god, I'm getting them silent.
I did a macarina.
Hello.
Hello, you want to do a macarina?
I'm doing a macarina, Lego.
That's so cute.
That's actually so cute.
Lego that fuck.
I wish that was real.
Hello.
How do we make...
How do we make a song?
Find and place dancers to bring the music video to life.
Don't worry, little one.
You're safe now.
I will save you.
Now you will be a dancer now.
I got you.
I got you little bit.
You can hear me though.
I got you, little boy.
You shall dance for me now.
Yeah, we're building around the world.
The world around the world.
Oh my god, there's a plat.
Yeah, I know.
Oh my god, there's a statue.
Two more.
Got you.
You shall go around the world.
My little one.
Here we go.
Oh my god, we can collect more stuff.
Look at them girls.
They're walking around the world.
Dance in front of them.
a bioscanner where's that
the world around now
make you a star you
would be a star now
how do we where's the bioscanner
we're just replacing this slowly i don't know where we don't want them go on the world here where the fuck is a bioscanner is it this oh I could change the color the back left oh here oh there it is I
can't believe I can get Wait, oh my god, they have around the world, too!
Around.
That, oh my god, my little truck.
Oh my god.
Look at all the Lego dancing.
And you have to sell.
Oh my god, John has food!
And I'm like, look at this.
I have to look at the...
No, no.
Boogie down.
Oh my god.
I love all the Lego.
emotes.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O.
Was it the glitter one too?
I can't believe I have Lego animation for all of this.
That's so funny.
Oh I even, I'm ripping it on the guitar too.
I like how I could do the macarina.
I'm very easily entertained.
Down the world.
Keep going around the world.
Never stop.
I will make you a star, baby.
That's right.
Keep walking.
Yes!
I'll make you a star.
You'll be famous.
I'm back to the death mode.
experience.
The last room just replaced the intro cinematic.
Was that one more time?
Wait, let me in, let me in, let me in.
Where am I?
No!
My bad fuck!
My bad fuck down!
Where am I?
I don't know where I am.
But this is beautiful.
How did I get here?
Got it.
Oh.
Oh, this is re-experience.
I literally glitched into here.
What the fuck?
Oh, this has to be the intro, right?
This is re-experiencing the...
I'm in the secret matrix level.
I don't know how I got there.
I got the backstage pass.
Oh, this is the last room, right?
What?
I'm stuck in the daft room.
And this is the best concept.
Fortnite has ever done.
I don't think I've ever experienced.
Like, the fact that this whole experience has been crazy.
I'm so happy.
Also, I like, I think, like, the first time they, because I'm not lagging anymore, so I'm pretty sure the first time they did this, like, everything was just overload.
There were so many, I think it was because, like, so many people were in the server, too.
no i'm still i changed the settings
but it's still the same i just changed from epic to high
i have such a beautiful experience oh it's so boring i'm so sad i'll never even though they'll never get back together to be disappointed and keep on coping.
I'm happy that Fortnite did this.
I'm so happy Fortnite did this.
It's been so fun.
I can't believe they made me relive trauma, though.
They made me relive my PTSD.
When I had to pick up Tomah's fucking helmet.
Like no, not again.
You can't do this to me.
Alright, it's time.
Around the world, around the...
It's time to do what I wanted to do.
World, around the world, around the world, around the world, around...
I don't know.
Make it.
Do it.
Peace us.
Lost card.
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
I fell 18 again listening to the stream.
More than hour.
Oh my god.
I don't want to leave.
I'm sorry.
Oh my.
The segues though in between songs are just so good Guys Around the world wait they release new merch
I gotta check Around the world around the world I'm gonna try my Around the world around the world The
Fortnite collection
I'm a little sad Oh my god Okay I would buy the U2s Or the What controller is that?
Okay Not gonna lie Okay The U2s is actually Really nice I will say Ah Okay Oh my gosh, I really like the YouTube.
I like the YouTube speaker.
Yeah, I was gonna say, what the fuck is this controller?
Did they hot fix the concert?
Because I'm not lagging anymore.
They must have hot fixed it or something.
Or like everything loaded in because I'm replaying.
Oh, there are too many people.
I won't be surprised.
This was an amazing experience.
I'm over.
I'm over here.
Never over.
Okay, I'll show you guys the...
I'll show you guys the figure.
Oh, wait.
I'll show you guys my helmet.
Wait, I'll take a picture of it right now.
Give me a sec.
I'll be right back.
again one more
time oh yeah oh my god just keep back in time for one more time
feedback just at the end of one more time.
I'll keep missing it one more time!
Oh my god, okay, okay, okay.
I can't post this on Twitter because, like, I have to mosaic it because of the reflections.
Well, I mosaic it right now.
I just don't think it'll be, like, a good quality picture of the tweet.
But, alright.
I'll show it on stream, though.
Oh my god, let me grab it.
Oh god, I love that plug so much.
Bum bum.
I hope the volume has been okay throughout it chat
I mosaic I mosaic all the reflections it's
perfect thank God I was still worried about the volume all right let me all right the picture is a little it's gonna be a little scuffed because I'm Try to make sure I'm going to erase the background a little bit too.
And then the thing I wish they could do,
a rerun concert, a reunion concert, only because knowing the technology we have today, it would have been fucking crazy.
Alright.
The technology we have today would have made this concert even crazy.
easier and that makes me sad we made an ira concert this so fucking good
here i legit have a real fucking daft i have a prop replica of a daft punk helmet and it's leds too it's led so it has so you see on the side this i even have the gloves i have the gloves i have his necklace from ram from random access memories i have the his ram necklace and also like his gloves like
that's how that's how hardcore i was as a fan i did i worn it before
for it too i wanted to cosplay him i wanted to i i had a picture of like a gender-bent version of of ghi manwell saved in my on my like phone for the longest time because i was like oh i want to do this cosplay but i never did i never did in the end i wish i did i mean i could still i could still i just need to get i i wish I still have the picture.
Oh, wait.
Maybe I can find it.
I'll find it.
I'll try to find it.
Daft, punk, female, yep, Manuel.
I wonder if I...
Oh my god.
I wonder if I still have the concept art of it.
I can still find it.
It was on...
It was on Tumblr.
The artist.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
gender bent tumbler
i don't know it's not in here i can't find it oh it was like it was such a cute design too it was so cute
It was so cute.
I wish I could find it.
You were mad.
You mean a female.
Oh wait.
Female Manuel.
I'm so happy.
All right, I think, I want to keep, I want to stay longer, but I'll be here forever.
I feel like, woman, femwell.
Yeah, that's so good.
Woman, femwell.
Oh, like that, boy.
I miss you.
Or, girl, fem, well.
I like that.
That's the best one.
Girl, fem, well.
Alright.
Before we go.
We gotta do one last time.
One more time.
We gotta do something one more time.
I am.
Gotta go to the jam dome, the jam sphere.
Why is there like pink and blue here?
His
first EDM concert took him to my jam session.
In the house!
We're up on stream to get Doki.
Champion, thank you for super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
I'm cooking.
I'm fucking cooking.
I could be rowing.
I love that punk so much.
I'm so happy.
I
love that punk.
And how sad I'm this guy.
Very funny.
Thank you.
Super Chinese.
I'm so happy that they did this collab.
I like how the disclaimer.
They were like, they're not getting back together, by the way.
They're like, please.
Keep your expectations low.
They're not actually getting back together.
And I'm like, don't say that.
Don't say that.
I think I saw the disclaimer.
They're like, they're not kids.
Yeah, I was just like, don't say that.
Give us a little why must you hurt us like this?
Like, stop coping.
This was such a great experience.
It was truly a Daft Punk experience.
The fact that they recreated a live 2007 for those who never ever got to experience it was crazy.
Whoever came up with that idea, he or she should get promoted.
That was honestly the best.
Like, for the event they've ever done.
Kiko, thank you for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for the jam session.
I was doing the jam.
I see you having me.
Hope that I keep doing it.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Magenta Supa.
I'm glad to make you happy.
I'm so happy too.
The fact that I feel like the concert they did had to be, like, the longest one.
for.
They use so much of their music.
You know, like during the interviews, like the the previews and the interviews and stuff about the event, they're like, oh, it doesn't seem like they're going to include much of their older songs.
But they included so they included almost all their songs in their old albums.
I was so happy.
Yeah, they were like, oh yeah, in the They're like, oh, they're just get lucky and around the world, like stuff like that, and they're like, oh, it's just most of the collab scams and stuff.
I was like, no, what?
Oh, they have so many good songs.
And then it was bait.
It was a bait and switch.
Oh my God, they lied to us.
They actually lied to us.
And I am so happy.
I was like, oh man, I'm sad that they won't include their classics but um I love their creatives because I was like please I want Technologic please oh I'm so happy they had Technologic too oh it's
not a regular concert and I was like oh but they lied it was a live 2007 tour I'm so happy I'm so happy they lied because I came in with lower expectations also the intro was fucking insane The intro and the intro was crazy.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, wait, I want to watch the intro again.
I want to watch the intro again.
It was so good.
We have to watch the intro again.
The intro went so high.
We'll end it with the intro.
I think the intro is just fucking crazy.
I was so coped for a live 2007.
They still make, like, guests.
It's not the same.
They make, like, surprise appearances.
But it's, like, it's not the same.
I didn't come here for Daft Punk to be a guest.
I want a soul.
I want...
They deserve to be the main guest.
The main performance.
I don't want them to be an add-on.
They deserve better.
It was so good.
Oh, my God.
For those who missed the intro, it again oh my god this was so beautiful with the with the reflection on my helmet too and we're about to go around the world and then the the crescendos they'd be like come take my hand i'll take you i'll take you to someplace special i'm like please let me leave this world i'm ready I will be ready.
I want to live in that punk's world.
It's so beautiful.
She's like, take my hand and I'll free you.
I'll free you from all the stress.
Take my hand and you don't have to suffer anymore and live in this cruel world.
I'll take your hand.
I'll take it.
Take me away.
I want to be free.
No, Toki, don't go.
Save me, anime woman.
Too bad for the people that got raptured.
You gotta miss out on pink.
a little pink that's right sucks for the fuck for those people thank god i sin too hard
they're missing out thank god i'm a sinner
who's this guy next to me whoa that guy's new
i've never seen him before he's next to me
Goodbye, stranger.
I have a stat, a montage.
Take my hand.
Anime woman.
Save me.
That was a death and death punk.
You're the punk and he's the death.
Blue woman, come back.
no back to my trauma
I'm back here oh we don't get to wear the helmet again I just noticed that
that was so good that was so good I'm so happy they skipped the try thank god thank god the trauma was a one time thing thank god They spared me.
I was like, not again.
No, I don't want to relive this.
Yeah, I played everything.
That was great.
I'm so happy.
What?
Honestly, what the fuck?
There's a bouncy.
There's a bouncy here.
That's funny.
And then...
Go back to the club.
Alright.
Well, go.
back to the club oh it's loading in oh i'll dance for my robot overlords i'll make them happy
uh magister thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i really was an amazing surprise seeing a sub china morning documentary thank you the super chat thank you oh i was so nervous for those who don't know I got interviewed by one of the Hong Kong's,
oh my gosh, it's so loud.
I know you guys can hear me.
But I got interviewed there, and I was very, I was very, like, nervous and scared about it because it was a big publication.
I'm happy that I didn't even watch the video because I'm too embarrassed
I'm too embarrassed I didn't watch the video itself but uh yeah the scmp interview yeah I'm I'm glad people enjoyed it
Oh, I even know who they interviewed.
That's the thing.
They didn't show me the video until it was published because they're like, oh, we wanted to make sure the integrity of everything.
So, like, you know, like to make sure no one was showing the video until it was published.
Or, like, shown what's in it until it was published.
Just because they're, like, journalistic.
So like in case like we don't influence on like how it's being edited or anything So so like they're like it's live now and I was so nervous like I hope I hope I said okay things Like I don't remember what I said.
I think like I got interviewed like I think like a month ago or something So I didn't even like remember what I said or what like what was the contents of the interview so
um white thank you the super chat thank you thank you um yeah the interviewer was also a dragon too so that's why they like approached me for the interview um the one of the the person that interviewed me was a dragon or is a dragon wait thank you super chat thank you thank you there's gonna be my happy place all weekend long we love our dokey pug uh jacardo thank you super chat thank you thank you sadly wasn't able to hit a daft punk concert idol which was a real bummer since i love their music and the robots but watching doki do this daft punk experience has been a good replacement and he was super chat thank you thank you yeah yeah there's dragons everywhere and that's why they asked that's why he like uh hit me up for an interview five give me my back the music so yeah i'm glad like everyone liked the interview or like like the video because i was so nervous about it
Anyway, I'm back on the main stage Because the closer you are to the stage, the louder it is
Magister, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you Interviewed, Dragoon, are you in here?
Please reveal yourself Okay, I have another stream tonight So I gotta rest a bit I was so tired before the stream And also like the first like minutes of the stream but the moment we got transported into like the intro like my energy love i was like like my energy levels was like up like at 10 at that point at too much energy at that point yeah it like replenished everything i was so hyped it revitalized me all right oh thank you all for experiencing the death punk experience with me i got up so early for them but it was worth it i can't believe they i can't they're like okay but the the time is perfect for the europeans like it makes sense because they're french but still it's not fair i had to rave in the morning
the eu coons that night, but I have to rave in the morning.
It's not fair.
How dare the French do this?
Next to you, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So glad we got to experience this, let you.
Your energy and love for Dad Punk is so pure.
It makes us all very happy.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
That was great.
It was an amazing experience.
And I'm dancing for my robot overlords.
And I will never stop dancing here again.
And if I...
To give it up.
Who we are.
Alright guys.
Because I'll be here forever.
If I don't stop dancing.
But I just want to dance.
But I have to go.
At the rest for tonight's stream.
And give Chad his walk.
He's done with his concert.
Alright guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around, get that blood going.
If you stayed up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys all tonight.
Thank you all for coming, everyone, and for experiencing a da-punk experience with me.
It was great.
happy this is everything i wanted and i exceeded my expectations and more i'm so happy
it's beautiful hey i'll see you guys later everyone thank you for the magenta super ugly thank you thank you it was worth it not gonna lie seeing blue women again i feel so loud almost made me cry oh thank you it's super chat thank you thank you don't get to speak for all dracus i'll say that Glad that you're so happy.
We drag those love you.
Thank you, it was Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, you guys didn't know.
These little fun facts.
That punk are weaves.
They were the OG weaves back then.
They literally went to Tokyo and did, like, interviews in Tokyo to, like, and, like, scouting on animation studios for, like, interstellar movie.
They're actual weaves, too.
yeah they love anime they literally made an anime movie they are the og weaves and they made blue women they were weaves when being a weave made you get stuffed in the locker but they didn't care they were the og weaves out there so okay i would say like check out the interviews they did in watching their interviews when they were in Tokyo and like oh my god it's so fucking cute I love it all right I'll see you guys bye everybody bye bye